Votto cures up after two years of
negotiations the european parliament has
finalised one of its biggest years the
reform of the Common Agricultural Policy
the cap for the period 2014 to 2020 the
budget allocated to European agriculture
has decreased by almost ten percent the
amount agreed on for the next seven
years consists of 380 billion euros but
how would this money be divided up and
who will be the beneficiaries big farms
will no longer profit from the money
coming from the cap no more than three
hundred thousand euros will be allocated
from now on but member states have been
allowed great leeway a vaunted política
yangtze now montfort duper lament
pretend limited ajudar all major
beneficiaries poor forma que como ESA's
Pope answers Tsubasa real force our war
cement Doozer movimento growl Katara you
marriage tree we saw my sister pool
autos Agriculture's improvement ground
the Greens in the European Parliament
have a completely different opinion epic
voters you're doing man Charlie's as you
see some copies 000 fasala prefer non
disease in 20 to grow a great manager
continue ha ha savad Emilio pondan Club
caveats increase economic social some
proceed on the new agricultural policy
will also be more in line with the
environment from now on thirty percent
of all direct payments will be linked to
sustainable practices such as the
maintenance of permanent meadows or the
diversification of cultures but the camp
is supposed to address other funding
issues to Loserville uncle Chris DiMarco
Xavi besoin de aqui tambien for me it
wasn't a equal to an occasion travaux
noodle machine Illustrated kiss to
extreme importance on observable novel
road we could see spokes on that if you
took homework the trans icon over an
additional twenty five percent of
financial aid will be allocated to young
farmers in their first five years of
activity to help them get started